mais qui sait mois et entre un père qui
me trouvent trop trop grand mère un peu
déjanté puis le couple au milieu ça mon
fruits 2
georges pas facile de trouver sa place
pourquoi je vous dis tu as de la chance
d'être personnes
voir si je suis personne quoi tu vas pas
voir jean-marie pour être prêté un stage
à vous proposer ou un stage
c'est l'impression d'avoir pris perpet
tout fait de plus beau à saillé à la
veille de l'eau quoi le premier soir
trouve ça bizarre mais toi tu trouve ça
bizarre je trouve ça carrément choquant
ni mon âme c'est la salle n'est mal
passé de l'île santos donc là c'est quoi
c'est une partouze
c'est pas vulgaire ceni annoncés pas
mignon alors plutôt atteint sur les
toits et séminaires et qui se pressent
le sait qu'il a passé sa jeunesse todor
vous avez oublié c'est bien la famille
leur masi chance ou les poêles à bois
les burqas un grillage qui fasse pour ne
voir que ou pour personne et s2
je suis très chiant ça y est tu as vu
comme une ère où les pêcheurs lui en a
c'est pas des yeux qu'il avait dragué
avec sa petite boîte à outils mort et
démonté pièce par pièce
attendant bulgarie mais j'étais avec mon
nom oui faute à quoi